you should walk with more respect you
are in a camp full of soldiers who have
been sitting still too long as I my
watch and see a true warrior in action
what have we here you come strutting
through our camp with such attitude
perhaps some one more thing would please
let us dance they're not bad ha who is
this little pipsqueak walking through
our camp perhaps I turn you into a pin
cushion you think so
this is a military very well let us
dance then
my sword arm has had little practice
since coming to stormhaven you look like
you might make good sport you think so
here's the person that uncovered the
plot against the king hail hero hmm you
don't look so dangerous eerie waltz into
my camp and big fights with my soldiers
tell me why I should not simply cut off
your head will you stand the princess
she is all right there that is good King
for Azad sent me to protect her but
there is little I can do from out here I
do not wish to start a war but I will if
my King orders it iowa new orders even
now hmm the princess she is all right
there ah yes indeed the poison maker was
quite stubborn but he spoken name with
his dying breath she is then she's and
the castle rollin quickly tell a comma
so that she may be prepared for this
wench assassin all right